what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so Batman lost from Dark Knight's
mettle is probably one of the best
stories in Dark Knight's metal it is
absolutely amazing because it's almost
like this love letter from like Snider
and James tending and all these guys to
the Batman mythos because we basically
see a lot of these things that have
happened over the course of Batman's
history thrown into this story now what
did he keep in mind is that remember
this is basically just Batman in the
dark multiverse that's all this is but
this is super cool because this story
reminds me of the episode tempest from
Outer Limits I don't know how many of
you guys ever saw that but it was a
super cool episode now we'll talk about
that once we get to the end of the video
but the cool thing about this is that
for those of you guys who were just now
joining us you remember all we really
knew was that for some reason or another
Batman was the vessel the means by which
Barbados would come into the main DC
Universe and that was it I mean of
course that a lot of that stuff still
being fleshed out this gives us a lot of
the answers to the questions that we've
been asking but the funny thing is that
once we get to the end it'll basically
say are these true or are they false
are they real answers or are they fake
answers and that's what's so cool about
all this so the funny thing is that with
Batman having been transported to the
Dark multiverse
when Barbados and his forces entered
again that was the nature but it was the
idea
Batman would be the vessel he would go
to the dark multiverse in Barbados and
the Dark Knight's
would come to the positive DC multiverse
basically to earth zero and so this
picks up with that whole scenario but
crazily enough it picks up with Bruce
Wayne when he's 78 years old and that's
a crazy thing about this is because it's
like his granddaughter sitting on his
lap right you know when she's like hey
tell me another story I want a real
story something that actually happened
and it's kind of funny here because what
Bruce Wayne does or at least what his
granddaughter does it's pulled down a
book or at least one of the cases that
Batman went over called the case of the
chemical syndicate now this is really
really really awesome for a couple
reasons the first is because of the fact
that one of the things that Bruce Wayne
says here and one of the things that DC
saying basically is that all the stories
that we've ever read about Batman
actually happened they might contradict
each other but they all happen the other
half is that the case of the chemical
syndicate that was the first story
Batman ever appeared in in Detective
Comics number 27 back in 1939 that was
his first story now the funny thing is
that they start from the beginning right
like Batman starts the beginning of the
story you know and says wow I mean I was
picking up with this guy I was meeting
with you know
Jr you know because of the fact that he
been framed for his father's murder but
right off the bat if you ever read
Detective Comics number 27 right off the
bat this is not the way it went that's
not the way the story opened the story
opened with Commissioner Gordon running
over the events of the entire story with
Bruce Wayne Commissioner Gordon didn't
know Bruce Wayne was Batman and the
reader didn't know Bruce Wayne was
Batman until the end of the original
story but in this scenario Bruce
basically tracks down
Lambert jr. the son of a guy named
Lambert and the original stories we were
never given his first name his son was
the one who was framed for his murder
and Batman's immediate responses well I
know it wasn't you I mean you were the
one who basically picked the knife out
of your father's body that's why your
fingerprints were on it but in the
original Detective Comics number 27
story
Lambert jr. was picked up by the cops
and he was basically questioned by the
cops and that's where this all came in
and that's why it's cool because then he
starts saying things like well you know
there's always blood on this window
there's always birds that are crashing
into it because the way the windows
angled the birds can't see that there's
window panes there but right off the bat
Bruce Wayne basically says this isn't
right this is not how this story
unfolded because it's not it's not the
way the original detective comics number
27 story unfolded and that's important
to remember here because what's going to
happen is that as we go through this all
these moments in Batman's history are
gonna crop up but none of them are going
to be the way they originally were the
next thing that is up happening here is
we basically jump to Grant Morrison's
Batman the return of Bruce Wayne now the
cool thing about this is that when it
came to the return of Bruce Wayne this
was the storyline that followed the
events of Final Crisis where Darkseid's
Omega sanction killed every single
person that was ever hit with it with
Bruce Wayne it sent him back in time
because you know DC can't kill his
character off he sells too many comics
so as a result he was basically
time-displaced he was sent into the
distant past and what the return of
Bruce Wayne did was basically chronicled
Bruce Wayne from the very distant past
all the way up into the point when he
was finally discovered by the Justice
League and brought back to the modern
day but what this does is it basically
grabs all the concepts of Dark Knight's
medal and rolls them into this whole
thing remember with regards to Barbados
all we knew was that he had like walked
the earth somewhere along the line and
he had been like defeated by Hawkman and
that was really about it we didn't
really know anything about it what we
end up finding out is that much like
Grant Morrison established when Batman
was transported back to the distant past
again basically drawing bat symbols on
walls to remind himself of who he was
the problem with this is that the bat is
the symbol of Barbados Bruce Wayne
didn't know this all he knew was that he
was just trying to remind himself of who
he was but by drawing this bat symbol on
a wall it basically led to the formation
of the tribe of the bat ie these people
who lived in the main DC Universe and
effectively allied himself with Barbados
never knowing that they were actually
doing that and that's why this is
important is because when hath-set
basically became the leader of this bat
rod and went to war against the bird
tribe that what this meant was that it
allowed Barbados and opening a source in
the sense the Barbados basically seemed
to grab in metal throw it to hath-set
and say here's your weapon to defeat the
bird tribe in turn hath-set use that
against the bird tribe Carter Hall in
the process Carter Hall was basically
killed and then began going to this
whole process of death and resurrection
at Hawkman but all this stems back to
the actions of Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne
was sent to the distant past by darkside
Bruce Wayne drew a bat symbol Bruce
Wayne inspired the formation of the bat
tribe because of the fact that Bruce
Wayne was sitting to the distant past
Barbados saw Bruce Wayne for the first
time and just watched him just started
watching things unfold and when people
began swearing allegiance to the batch
rod which was basically just something
that kind of came into existence because
of Bruce Wayne's cave drawings Barbados
came to the realization he could use
that as a means to have that tribe
follow his belief system and then use
that tried to bring himself into the
main DC Universe that's the crazy thing
about all this is because he's basically
the one dead set all this stuff in
motion the problem is that again
somewhere along the line Barbados
managed to make his way into the actual
DC Universe he was defeated by the bird
tribe after hath-set was defeated and he
was confined back and that's when
Barbados came to realize that it's not
enough for people to just worship Him
and him to step into the realm what he
needs is an anchor he needs someone who
sort of represents this kind of ethereal
connection some sort of intangible
connection that hasn't been explained
yet they can basically be a
quote-unquote vessel for him that will
allow him to step into the main DC
Universe so long as that person goes
into the dark multiverse and that's the
nature of Bruce Wayne now how it is that
we got from point A to point B that's
what's explained here all these moments
really just sort of picked up Damian
Wayne from Batman in Bethlehem the
future version of Damian
Wayne who's just cold-blooded the newest
version of Batman all these different
versions basically to start kind of
cropping up but it's these perverted
iterations these stories that DC's
written over the years that are twisted
that are screwed up that are not the way
that they're supposed to be even with
the character of Thomas Wayne as far as
Bruce Wayne's concerned Thomas Wayne is
this sort of upstanding guy he's his
father he's the man that always did the
right thing and a lot of the moral
viewpoints that Bruce Wayne has he got
from his father what seems to happen
here is that as he's sort of just
jumping through all these different
points in his life past and present and
even a life that he never lived he
basically sort of picks up his Thomas
Wayne only to find out that Thomas Wayne
was part of the bat tribe and Thomas
Wayne was one of the people who served
the purpose of trying to bring Barbados
into the main DC Universe now where the
other members of the batch rod aren't
really ready for that kind of an act to
basically condemn this girl to death
Thomas Wayne seems like he is you know
and he immediately goes to sort of turn
the knife on this girl now of course all
the other guys run out you know when
everything begins to go crazy and the
play starts burning down but then this
girl seems to suddenly transform into
Catwoman or the very least looks like
Selina Kyle and basically begins
describing exactly how everything played
out the way it originally took place in
the sense that well you know she's
basically locked inside this room she'll
eventually burn alive and that will be
it the purpose of this tribe will be to
bring Barbados into the DC Universe only
to find out they can't after that he's
immediately sent to another place in
time where the Joker has become mayor
now this seems to hit at the idea of
like Batman endgame dirty sky Snyder's
run in Batman in game The Joker
basically exposed the entire city of
Gotham to the Joker toxin and everybody
went crazy but then suddenly it flips on
his head and what we end up finding out
is that in this particular universe that
exists out there that people got tired
of superheroes and instead they allied
themselves with the bad guys the average
person going to their nine-to-five job
the average mom the average dad they got
tired or everything Batman stood for and
chose the Joker they chose all the
villains the villains took this
opportunity to rise up to prominence and
basically conquer the world tracking
down every single superhero they could
find and basically killing them at this
point it immediately jumps again and we
pick up with Allan Wayne and this one
Allan Wayne is kind of like this
perversion of the way his character was
originally depicted remember and Scott
Snyder's run of Batman Allan Wayne was
established as the guy who had basically
gone through and spearheaded the
elevation of Gotham from being just this
sort of small town into being this
massive metropolitan area he started all
these different foundations but Allen
Wayne was the first one to realize the
court of owls was real this clandestine
organization that lived within Gotham
City it was composed of the rich and
powerful people who were trying to
basically control the city itself with
regards to this in terms of how it
compares to Dark Knights metal we're not
given an explanation of that we're kind
of left to believe that Allen Wayne
figured out that the court of owls
because they serve the purpose of
ensuring that some future person of the
Wayne family would basically be exposed
to all these metals which would turn him
into a vessel that could lead to
Barbados has returned where Allen Wayne
seems to be the one to realize that all
these different buildings have been
basically composed or been doused with
these you know particular metals at the
court of values you know within fettle
more or less but he's immediately killed
by talent and then it picks up with him
running through the street in scott
Snyder's run it didn't play out that way
and Scott Snyder's Ron it was basically
just Allen Wayne being the guy to figure
out that the court of owls existed he
had no idea what they were about but he
knew that they had sinister plans he ran
through the street you know screaming
like a lunatic came across some cops
from cops said hey man hold on for a
second then he was yanked into a sewer
by the talent the assassin of the court
of owls and that was it but it's
basically grabbing these ideas and it's
rolling them in giving us alternate
reality depictions of these characters
and so then we end up jumping back to
the original case of the chemical
syndicate and his basically Batman
realizing the significance of these
birds that he surrounds himself with
birds in order to always remember who he
is and this is where the symbolism
begins to come into play when we end up
seeing Superman and Nightwing and so the
implication here means one of two things
either it means people who can fly it
means Robins or it means both and so
because of that is basically Batman
surrounding himself with people who are
tried and true
so the Batman can always basically
maintain this ideology that sometimes he
does what they wouldn't do that he's got
a heavier hand that he may stumble he
may fall and there's a possibility he
might lose his way but in order to make
sure he doesn't he anchors himself to
people who in a lot of ways are morally
greater than he is and that's why this
is so cool but it's also the idea with
regards to these birds as Batman kind of
saying hey look birds are attracted to
like strange metals different things
like that if the birds are flying into
this window they're heading for
something in particular which means
they've gone to this window where would
they have landed and that's what leads
him to this trap door wasn't witching
back to him as an old man telling the
story suddenly if snow his granddaughter
freaking out and acting all you know
demonic but it's also because of the
fact that this 78 year old Bruce Wayne
also knows that something's not right
here that all these moments quote
unquote
in his life all these experiences that
he's gone through all these stories that
he's told all this history that he's
aware of happened a way that he
remembers but the way that he's
recounting it to his granddaughter it
never happened that way it's all wrong
somehow and that's the idea of Barbados
popping up this is where we started to
get into all these different questions
and all these different answers and the
question of whether or not any of them
are legit what Barbados basically says
is your life is the way it is because I
made it that way because I've made you
the person that you are every single
circumstance that you've gone through in
your life every case you've solved every
clue that's been there I've been there
to make sure that you turn out that way
and he even goes as far it's a display
the entire dark multiverse he says look
my dark nights represent a handful of
them the stories that you've jumped
through these alternate reality event
that have taken place where things have
been darker they've been more screwed up
that's only a handful you've seen at
most maybe a little less than a dozen
but there are thousands of these worlds
where everything that can go wrong has
gone wrong and I have the power to grab
these worlds and bring them in to the
main DC Universe to bring everything you
know and love crashing down around you
and that's when he starts showing him
all the dark knights who are taking out
the superheroes flash facing off against
Red Death in this alternate story Batman
becomes a God of War all the origin
stories that we've seen so far that's
all of them that are here and it's him
saying I have all these universes where
everyone you know and everyone you love
is dead because of you you killed them
you destroyed each and every one of
these universes and that hits home at
the nature of this comic and it hits
home at Batman's absolute greatest fear
the fact that he will fail that he'll
lose everything he loves because he'll
inevitably screw up it's Batman feeling
a sense of hopelessness but that's where
the question suddenly gets yanked away
because we feel like we finally have an
answer to this where we feel like we
finally have an origin to who it is that
Barbados is
we suddenly yanked back to the beginning
of the comic and the cycle repeats
itself and that's why this is so cool
because again this reminds me of the
whole tempest story if you guys never
saw that episode from the Outer Limits
it was super cool it's like this captain
of a ship is basically trying to get
back to his home colony on some other
planet after having arrived on earth to
get a cure for some illness called
Alyssia sea which causes hallucinations
along the way they fly through like a
gravity well or something along those
lines but they end up on like some weird
derelict planet where like they get
stuck inside some living being or
somebody that their ship has swallowed
or something along those lines but when
they go to investigate what it is ah the
captain's bit by like one of these weird
spiders and then suddenly there's like
two alternate scenarios that are taking
place he's hallucinating events in one
event he successfully made it back and
he saved the people on his colony but
he's suffering the effects of Alyssia
see where he's basically experiencing
hallucinations in the other event he's
still on the ship and he's experiencing
hallucinations because of the spider
bite but with regards to both stories in
the the story where he made it back to
his own world where you made it back to
his own colony they say well the images
you're seeing the story that you're
seeing about who experiencing the spider
bite and suffering hallucinations
that's a hallucination but when he's on
the ship they say well the spider bites
giving you a hallucination that you made
it back to your colony at the end of the
episode you find out neither one of
those stories is true that instead he
was bitten by one of the spiders and
he's basically living a series of
hallucinations and so is everybody else
on the ship and they're basically just
being consumed alive by these spiders
and they're stuck in an endless loop of
hallucinations but that's what this
reminds me of is because it's basically
Batman stuck inside the dark multiverse
he's locked in a dream it's almost
matrix
esque in terms of how it unfolds there's
no legitimate escape here for him and
what he's experiencing are all these
terrible scenarios in his subconscious
and that's why I say we don't know if
Barbados appearing to him and saying
there's thousands of all these worlds
that have these terrible scenarios we
don't know if that's true that's the
cool thing about this is that for every
answer that we're given we're basically
asked the question is this answer true
or is this answer false and I'm not
gonna tell you which would that be said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you